what are your thoughts about the James
Webb Space Telescope
um is this as somebody who likes
telescopes and this is one of the I
think it says um
take 20 years to build 9.7 billion
dollars is that way too much too little
are you excited about this thing it's
it's sufficiently different from what I
do in my field that it's incredibly
interesting to me because it's it's it's
I have no you know horse in that race
and so I'm not competing with them for
time or money or resources or people or
whatever so I can purely be an advocate
and an Aficionado of science it is in
some sense the successor to Hubble it
will do things that Hubble can't do it
will also may or may not have the impact
on a visceral kind of artistic level
that hobblehand what are some of the
most iconic things that Hubble did the
Hubble Ultra Deep Field The Pillars of
Creation you know storms and and imaging
and of these Twisted deep Galaxy deep
Sky galaxies those resonated with the
public just visually they're beautiful
yeah when you look at um these images
the Hubble Ultra Deep Field you'll maybe
put that in you'll show every Speck of
light except for one one four thousand
Blobs of light of this one star in our
galaxy the rest are galaxies now that
image is less than one tenth of your
fingernail held at arm's length it
contains four thousand galaxies so now
you can figure out how many galaxies
there are in the whole Sky just by
seeing how long does it take you to move
your fingernail over the whole sky so we
have another couple hours no so it comes
out to be that's how we get 500 billion
or more galaxies now it's not exact to
the Galaxy but it's it's a good order of
magnitude estimate maybe even better
um Hubble produced that and it was
basically serendipitous they pointed
some dark blank piece of Sky what they
thought was blank and they saw it same
thing that happened with the CMB they
were looking they were something they
didn't find same thing they found when
they were looking for the deceleration
of the universe and found it was Axel
already
um so when I um sometimes hear is that
we don't know what we're going to
discover I never think that's a good
idea to spend billions of dollars on
something like you should have some
guaranteed low-hanging fruit and then
there should be swinging for the fences
and I think in this case it was really
everything is swinging for the fences
because it's either it's kind of a
single point failure if that telescope
which is this origami construction of 22
hexagonal panels that have to unfold
properly and then Orient themselves a
million miles from Earth beyond the
Earth Moon distance by a factor of four
and and still transmit telecommunity you
know telecommunication back to the Earth
get solar energy keep it away from the
Sun you know you don't want to look
through the telescope of the sun with
your remaining good eye and you do that
and you cover it's going to be
phenomenal I I um for science for sure
if it works
there are a lot of people think you know
it's so risky it's such a NASA sunk so
much of their budget it ate up you know
and what if it does fail I mean there's
no guarantee yes it's insured but so
what you're not going to get back those
20 years of people let's start building
it again like they didn't build two
copies of it
um and then if it fails it kind of
has a dampening effect
on the prospects and the inspiration of
the public for the what science can do
what science engineering can do is all
in space it will make a huge impact
scientific let's hope for the best let's
assume it does succeed it's launched in
a couple weeks and um and when it does
it will transform our understanding of
you know we just discovered not only
like extrasolar planets that have moons
on them and asteroid belt we discovered
an extrasolar planet in another galaxy
this will be able to see crazy stuff
like that spectroscopy Imaging
um but but it's and it'll be able to go
back farther in time such that we'll be
doing Cosmo like Hubble did some
cosmology I measured the Hubble constant
that was this key project when it was
designed and launched
um but because it is optical telescope
it's sensitive to more you know close in
redshifts so shorter distances now James
Webb is much much higher redshift it can
probe the darker deeper distant universe